[موسيقى] في
كل مرة أرقص فيها أحاول أن أبذل قصارى جهدي وأبذل
قصارى جهدي لأن العيش
في العالم علمني أنه ربما هذه المرة
ستكون آخر رقصة بالنسبة لك ،
ربما تُقتل في قنبلة أو رصاصة أو
شيء ما عندما  غادر الاستوديو ، لذلك في
كل مرة أبذل قصارى جهدي
وأعيشه على
أفضل وجه.  شاهدت الرقص لأول مرة عندما
كنت طفلاً في الثامنة من عمري لأنني
كنت مفتونًا بحركتهم
والموسيقى التي يحركونها ، تعلمت
كيفية الرقص من خلال مقاطع الفيديو على YouTube
وكنت أفعل ذلك كل يوم في غرفتي
سراً لأنني أرقص  في جامعي
خاصة بالنسبة للرجل ، هناك
شيء يخجلني من أن حياتي كانت في خطر عندما
كنت في سوريا لأنني كنت
راقصة وهذا بسبب المتطرفين
الذين جاءوا إلى بلدنا وبعد
ذلك كنت سأبدأ في استقبال  كل هذه
الرسائل أو المكالمات الهاتفية أو تلك
الأشياء التي تخبرني أنهم يريدون قطع
رأسي وهذا هو السبب في أنني
أرقص وشمي أو أموت
مني لأنني أحمل حياتي على رقبتي وإذا
كانوا سيقتلونني أريد ذلك  أن
يكون آخر شيء يمكنهم رؤيته مني ،
لذا فهو يرقص أو يموت أثناء وجوده في سوريا ،
ذهب أحمد لتلقي تدريب رسمي على الرقص
وكان ينشر مقاطع فيديو
لرقصه واكتشفه في النهاية
صانع أفلام وثائقية من هولندا
أراد أن يروي قصته
شاهد الفيلم فرقة الباليه الوطنية الهولندية التي
قدمت له منحة دراسية
ذهب إليها منذ ذلك الحين ليؤديها في جميع أنحاء أوروبا ،
نحن هنا في مسارح
نتحدث عن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في هذا
الإنتاج ، أنا أتصرف بنفسي لأن
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لعبت الدور الأكثر أهمية
في إنقاذ حياتي في قصتي
لأنني شاهدت عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وتم إنقاذي مما جعلني أستمر في
الرقص وأستمر في فعل ما
أفعله حتى اليوم لأنني أعتقد
أن الفنان لديه نفس الواجب  مثل
الجندي الذي يقاتل من أجل بلاده
والفنان يمكن أن يناضل من أجل الشخصية من أجل الفن
والتاريخ وإذا لم يكن لدينا فن
وثقافة في بلادنا فماذا نحارب
بعيدًا عن ذلك فأنا لا شيء وليس لدي أي
شيء كل ما لدي  هل هذا وكل ما أنا عليه
هو الراقصة وربما في المستقبل البعيد
أحيانًا أرى نفسي جالسًا
على الكرسي كرجل عجوز في المسارح في
سوريا أقوم بإخراج فرقة الباليه الوطنية السورية
التي سأجدها لذلك آمل
أن يتحقق هذا الحلم
[موسيقى
]  أنت